bonjour olivier mardi et au merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france
comment est ce que vous étiez ces
révélations qui ont fuité dans la presse
les terrasses le 17 mai les salles à
l'intérieur entre le 1er et le 15 juin
réalisme ou utopique
déjà les promesses n'engagent que ceux
qui les écoutent
donc là on est même pas au stade des
promesses mais si on fait un parallèle
c'est grosso modo le calendrier de
l'année dernière donc à résoudre parce
qu'on pourrait déjà réouvert d'opéra ces
gens sont dehors
on sait qu' il n'y a pas de souci majeur
quand on est à l'extérieur
donc oui le 17 mai pourquoi pas mercredi
sans emmanuel macron avait déjà évoqué
la carotte de la mi mai or on sait que
on sait que les clauses de revoyure ont
souvent douché les espoirs du secteur
perspective de clarté nécessaire pour
redonner espoir aux bien mieux valait ne
rien dire pour éviter de faux espoirs
envoie coup de com ou bien bien
nécessaire non mais très sincèrement
dans la profession on se doute tous
depuis depuis très longtemps que ne
serait ce qu'avec la saisonnalité et
comme les dernières avec le printemps
les beaux jours on va on va on va
réouvrir ou moins les au moins les
terrasses donc c'est un effet c'est un
effet d'annoncé aussi je pense que pour
eux pour faire pour donner un peu
d'espoir aux gens et là nous mais nous
on est toujours un peu circonspect voyez
on entrave ni parler ou de deux mètres
des plus qu'au delà sur les qr codes sur
les tables pour tracer pour que les gens
soient tracées
le problème avec ça c'est s'il y met
autant de ils sont aussi rapides pour
sortir les plus arcade que quand ils
nous sortent les attestations on aura
les dates d'ouverture on n'aura pas de
matériel pour les faire donc
ce qui sera intéressant c'est que
réellement y mettre en place un plan
avec les qr codes comment les utilisent
pour qui ces imprimés et conduite et que
le jour j
on nous ressort les tables et on
commence à travailler outre les qr codes
donc pistes évoquées par nos confrères
du point
avec quelles pistes vous souhaiteriez
pour justement pouvoir ouvrir sans trop
de difficulté on parle également d'une
jauge à 50%
moi par exemple je vous demandais quand
pourrais-je est un géant bistrot il est
bassin de la villette donc j'ai des
quais très large devant devant chez moi
aujourd'hui les gens et c'est très
agréable à vivre
il jouait la paix tant qu'ils s'assoient
sur les bancs ils se promènent j'aurai
une terrasse qui est dehors les gens sa
série sur la terrasse plutôt que sur les
bancs donc on est en train d'essayer
toujours de légiférer de mettre à quatre
est formel et cetera etc
je pense qu'aujourd'hui les gens sont
sont responsables dans leur grande
majorité à partir du moment où une colle
pas les tables à partir du moment où
effectivement les gens respectent le
nombre maximum de personnes etc
on pourrait ré ouvrir simplement et je
sais pas pourquoi on veut toujours
complexifier à l'extrême et tout codifié
pour faire des choses qui au bout du
compte s'avère une applicable 1 où juste
un effet d'annoncé je vous prends
l'exemple des cahiers de rappel qui
avait été mis en place l'année dernière
il ne servait à rien alors on passait
notre temps faire remplir les
coordonnées aux gens moi j'ai eu deux
cas de personnes qui avaient fait un
test avant de venir au bistrot et qui
ont eu leurs résultats après qui m'ont
rappelé je leur ai donné tous tes
coordonnées pour que effectivement leur
centre de sécu puisse avoir le cahier
drapés des voix requis tête lorsqu'on ne
sait que leur a rappelé qu'ils n'étaient
pas équipés et qu'ils n'avaient pas le
temps de gérer ça voyez donc à un moment
j'ai eu l'impression d'avoir bossé donc
j'espère qu'avec leurs applications
populaires quoi c'est pas juste un effet
d'annoncé qu'effectivement ils vont
donner du staff problèmes de connexion
avec olivier marquettoise que vous êtes
toujours là vous parlez d'un problème
d'effectifs
ouais vous m'entendez ou pas oui c'est
bon vous en étiez au mot star dans
l'effectif on fronce eh oui pardon
ouais non mais je pense qu'il ya un
problème d'effectif qui vont avoir pour
gérer aussi toutes les remontées d'un
faux
donc mettre en place des mesures
musclées avec des données qui ne seront
pas capables de traiter parce qu'ils
vont manquer de personnel dans les dents
les cpam etc
c'est un petit peu c'est un petit peu
ridicule
olivier martin et aux questions un peu
plus terre-à-terre pas sur l'arrivée de
vos clients dans les restaurants mais
sur vos confrères et même vous même est
ce que vous avez une idée de la part de
restaurants qui seront capacité
économiquement de pouvoir rouvrir
quand le temps sera venu après avoir
passé beaucoup de temps les rideaux
fermés est ce que vous disposez de
chiffres sur le nombre de dépôts de
bilan à venir de la part de vos
confrères n'ont pour l'instant c'est
vous savez chacun essaye de chacun
essaye de se battre je pense que pour
votre question est là est la vraie sens
par rapport à ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui faut savoir qu'aujourd'hui
il ya des milliers de restaurateurs des
commerçants aussi un quinon qui ne
touchent pas leur fonds de solidarité
depuis des mois donc ce qui serait très
bien aussi de la part du gouvernement
c'est avant de mettre en place des
nouvelles mesures c'est déjà de faire
appliquer celles qui sont en cours
aujourd'hui
je comprends que mon exemple très
rapidement moi je n'ai pas touché mon
fonds de solidarité depuis le mois
décembre
grosso modo j'ai plus de 30000 euros qui
sont dehors
ces trente mille euros sont censés
servir à payer un des fournisseurs à
payer les loyers et c'est donc
aujourd'hui comment on fait heureusement
que moi j'ai la vente à emporter que
j'ai avec lui sur un endroit qui est
plutôt bien placé ça me permet ça me
permet de tenir une façon très serré
mais j'ai peur que les commerçants qui
aujourd'hui touchent pas leur compte
solidarité qui ont leurs propriétaires
qui leur demandait pas de payer leur
loyer ou d'autres fournisseurs etc
à un moment avec une date qui recule de
plus en plus ce ne soit pas dans la
possibilité de réouvrir et finalement
c'est l'état qui les aura tué en ne
versant pas le champ pôle hilarité en
temps et en heure à ces personnes merci
olivier masetto d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
gérant du bistrot chez musique à paris